Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
À votre avis, combien de décisions
prenons-nous par jour en moyenne ?
35 ? 350 ?
3 500 ? 35 000 ?
35 000 en moyenne.
35 000 environ.
Céréales ou tartines ?
Baskets ou bottines ?
Chauffage à 19 °C ? 21 °C ?
Voiture ou vélo ?
Notre cerveau est une machine fantastique.
Une machine à apprendre.
Une machine à produire de l'intelligence.
Une machine à produire un nombre
impressionnant d'opérations à la seconde.
Ce qui en fait de loin l’ordinateur
le plus puissant à l’heure actuelle.
Alors pourquoi, même lorsque
nous souhaitons changer,
même lorsque nous avons
fait le choix de changer,
il est si difficile de changer ?
Les exemples sont nombreux.
Pourquoi je continue à acheter des objets,
parfois en double ou en triple,
alors que je n'en ai pas
forcément l'utilité ?
Ou des objets de même type pour remplacer
un objet qui fonctionne encore très bien ?
Pourquoi je continue à passer
autant de temps sur ce smartphone
alors même que je manque de temps
pour pratiquer une activité physique ?
Pourquoi je suis attirée
par ce vol low cost
pour mon prochain week-end à l’étranger
alors je sais que c’est mauvais
pour mon bilan carbone ?
Pourquoi ?
Parce que nous sommes humains,
tout simplement.
Et c’est ce PFH,
ce « putain de facteur humain »,
une expression québécoise qui a été
utilisée récemment par Hubert Reeves
pour décrire l’inaction des hommes
face à l’état de la Terre,
qui nous freine
dans nos velléités de changer.
Quelles sont ces forces invisibles
qui nous gouvernent
sans que nous en ayons
forcément conscience ?
Je vais vous faire
une petite démonstration.
Je vais vous demander de me dire
la couleur qui apparaît à l’écran.
Je vous demande de parler
à voix haute et bien fort.
Public : Bleu !
Sandrine Bélier : Allez-y !
Public : Vert ! Rouge ! Jaune !
SB : Bravo ! Encore !
La couleur d’écriture.
Public : Vert ! Rouge ! Bleu ! Jaune !
SB : Toujours la couleur d’écriture.
Allez-y !
Public : Vert ! Jaune ! Rouge !
Bleu ! Jaune ! Rouge !
Rouge ! Bleu !
SB : C’est une tâche classique,
un protocole de psychologie expérimentale
très classique, la « tâche de Stroop »,
qui nous montre à quel point il est
difficile de lutter contre les habitudes.
La lecture est quelque chose
de très automatisé pour le lecteur averti.
Difficile de lutter
contre nos automatismes
qui sont bien ancrés en mémoire.
Cela vient du fait que
nous pensons à deux vitesses.
C’est Daniel Kahneman qui a écrit
ces deux modes de pensée.
Un système 1,
très automatique, très rapide,
qui opère sans contrôle volontaire,
inconscient, intuitif,
émotionnel, stéréotypé.
Ce système 1 est utilisé
pour les activités routinières
comme conduire une voiture, lire un texte,
réaliser des calculs simples.
Il est très utile la plupart du temps car
il nous permet de réagir très rapidement,
de fuir par exemple un danger,
en classant en
« dangereux / pas dangereux »
une information qui se présente
à nous, par exemple.
Il demande très peu d’effort,
mais il nous fait aussi faire des erreurs,
et notamment des erreurs de jugement.
En parallèle de ça, Daniel
Kahneman a décrit un système 2 :
le mode mental adaptatif
qui est beaucoup plus rare, qui
demande beaucoup plus d’effort aussi,
qui est plus conscient, plus réfléchi.
Ce système 2 est utilisé pour s’adapter,
pour avancer, pour innover.
Il nous permet de nous projeter dans le
futur, d'analyser des données complexes,
de développer une stratégie,
d’assurer une régulation émotionnelle.
Mais il demande énormément d’effort.
Et d’ailleurs, si nous prenions
toutes nos décisions,
si nous traitions toute l’information,
via ce système 2,
ce serait beaucoup trop long,
beaucoup trop laborieux,
car ça prendrait trop de temps,
ça serait fastidieux, au vu de nos 35 000
décisions que nous prenons chaque jour.
La plupart de nos décisions sont
prises de façon non consciente.
99,74% de nos décisions sont prises
de façon non consciente.
Sur les 35 000 décisions,
ça fait seulement 100 décisions
que l’on prend de façon consciente.
Et les nouvelles technologies
et leur usage,
le manque de temps,
ne favorisent pas
la sollicitation de ce système 2
et, au contraire, nous poussent
à utiliser de plus en plus ce système 1.
Il faut dire que nous avons
une préférence naturelle du cerveau
à utiliser ce système 1.
Il faut savoir que le cerveau,
rien qu’en existant,
consomme déjà naturellement
20% des apports d’énergie.
Donc le cerveau va tout faire
pour ne consommer
aucune ressource d'énergie supplémentaire.
Il va tout faire
pour minimiser les efforts,
minimiser les dépenses
d’énergie supplémentaire
et passer en mode automatique
dès qu’il le peut.
Le problème est
que ce système automatique,
très efficace pour les tâches
connues, simples, familières,
s’avère peu adapté aux environnements
complexes d’aujourd’hui.
Par ailleurs, le système 1, automatique,
est aversif au risque,
résistant au changement,
paresseux en termes intellectuels
et vulnérable aux biais cognitifs.
Les biais cognitifs sont
des raccourcis de pensée
qui nous font aller vite et bien
la plupart du temps.
Difficile d'y échapper.
Comme le montre cette illustration,
plus de 200 biais cognitifs
ont été répertoriés.
Nous sommes tous gouvernés
par de nombreux biais cognitifs.
Le problème,
c’est que ces biais cognitifs,
même s’ils nous font réagir
rapidement, vite et bien,
ils nous font commettre
aussi des erreurs de jugement,
avoir des comportements irrationnels et
prendre des décisions parfois douteuses,
voire carrément mauvaises.
Je vais vous donner un exemple,
de nouveau, une petite illustration.
Je vais vous demander si, selon vous,
vous êtes bon conducteur
ou bonne conductrice.
Dans un coin de votre tête, je vais vous
demander de vous attribuer une note :
A, B, C ou D.
Qui a répondu D ?
Personne.
Super. On peut monter avec vous.
Qui a répondu C ?
Ben, il n’y a pas grand-monde
non plus, hein.
Donc en fait, vous êtes 800 et vous
êtes tous au-dessus de la moyenne.
(Rires)
C’est ce qu’on appelle -
(Applaudissements)
C’est ce qu’on appelle
le biais d’excès de confiance.
(Rires)
Même les personnes qui ont
causé un accident de voiture,
quand on les interroge,
90% d’entre elles pensent encore
être bon ou bonne conductrice.
On l’a vu, ces biais cognitifs,
il en existe de nombreux.
Il y en a qui interviennent encore
plus dans les situations de changement
et qui pourraient nous expliquer
pourquoi il est si difficile de changer,
pourquoi il y a une forme
de résistance au changement.
Je vais vous donner trois exemples.
Il y a l’effet d’autruche
qui nous pousse à regarder ailleurs,
qui nous pousse
à négliger l’information négative.
Et en particulier lorsque l'information
défavorable nous paraît lointaine.
Il y a le biais de statu quo,
qui fait qu’on préfère rester
dans notre état actuel,
un environnement connu, stable, familier,
plutôt que de prendre le risque
de changer, de faire autrement.
Il y a le biais de conformité sociale :
on est prêt à renoncer à des comportements
que l’on pense plus souhaitables
si ces comportements ne sont pas
valorisés par le groupe, par les autres.
Pourquoi ? Parce que
nous sommes des êtres sociaux
et que nous avons
besoin du regard des autres -
des autres - pour exister.
Nous préférons renoncer à nos
comportements plutôt que d’être exclu.
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait maintenant
pour changer au vu de tout ça ?
Nous sommes gouvernés
par de nombreux biais cognitifs.
Nous voulons changer plus durablement
pour nous sentir libre, plus juste.
Il y a des pistes externes
qui nous permettent de changer.
Comme les contraintes,
les lois, les interdictions.
On l’a vu pour le port
de la ceinture en voiture
ou pour l’interdiction de fumer
dans les restaurants.
Et ça marche, la preuve.
Il y a aussi des possibilités de changer
par des méthodes un peu plus douces,
toujours externes, mais
c’est ce qui va nous permettre
d'insister plutôt qu'imposer.
Ce sont les nudges.
Ce sont des coups de pouce,
des coups de coude
qui nous poussent à adopter
un comportement plus vertueux.
Les personnes qui créent ces nudges
utilisent les connaissances sur le
fonctionnement humain pour les créer.
Ils créent ces nudges pour nous pousser
à adopter un comportement
qui apparaît bon pour nous,
pour la planète, pour l’environnement.
Mais la limite du nudge,
c’est qu’il n’est pas apprenant.
C’est-à-dire que si on ne prend pas
conscience du fait qu’on a été nudgé,
il y a peu de chance
que le comportement vertueux
soit reproduit en l'absence du nudge.
Mais pire encore, si on prend
conscience qu’on a été nudgé,
on peut avoir le sentiment
d’avoir été manipulé,
ce qui peut nous pousser
à adopter le comportement contraire.
Je vous invite à lire
cette phrase d’Henri Laborit.
[Tant qu’on n’aura pas
diffusé très largement
à travers les hommes de cette planète
la façon dont fonctionne le cerveau,
la façon dont ils l’utilisent...]
Cette phrase nous fait réfléchir.
Elle nous montre
que si nous ne savons pas
comment nous fonctionnons,
d’autres le savent et peuvent l'utiliser.
Elle nous montre que si nous ne savons pas
comment nous fonctionnons,
nous sommes plus vulnérables
à la manipulation.
Ce sont ces connaissances
du fonctionnement du cerveau
qui vont nous permettre de développer
des pistes internes de changement.
C’est nous qui allons décider de changer,
de décider en parfaite conscience,
et de nous sentir plus juste, plus libre.
C’est le rôle que joue la métacognition,
la connaissance
du fonctionnement cognitif -
mémoire, attention, raisonnement -
et des facteurs qui influencent
ce fonctionnement cognitif
comme les biais cognitifs
que l’on vient de voir.
Cela paraît évident,
mais on ne nous apprend pas à l’école
comment fonctionne notre cerveau,
ni même à l’âge adulte.
Alors que connaître
le fonctionnement de son cerveau,
son potentiel, mais aussi ses limites,
apparaît essentiel.
Le développement de cette
métacognition va nous permettre
d’apprendre à penser contre soi,
contre ses automatismes,
et à développer des stratégies
pour contourner ses limites.
Et comme je vous l'ai dit, d'agir plus
justement, d'agir plus librement.
Une étude d’un géant
de la technologie a montré
que les personnes,
quand on les interrogeait,
avaient l’impression d’avoir
consulté leur téléphone 22 fois
contre 76 fois en réalité.
On voit bien que nous adoptons
des comportements très automatisés.
Une piste interne serait de développer
ce qu’on peut appeler des auto-nudgings -
« Je me nudge moi-même ».
Contrairement aux nudges
que j’ai présentés tout à l’heure -
« c’est l’autre qui me nudge » -
dans le cas de l’auto-nudging,
je me nudge moi-même
pour réduire mon incapacité d’agir,
pour me donner un coup de pouce
pour adopter ces comportements vertueux.
Dans le cas de l’utilisation trop
grande du téléphone portable,
un auto-nudge pourrait être simplement de
mettre son téléphone dans une autre pièce.
Vous allez voir que vous n’allez
plus le consulter automatiquement.
Je vous invite à réfléchir
aux comportements
que vous souhaitez désapprendre
pour inventer, pour créer,
vos propres auto-nudgings.
À vous de jouer.
(Applaudissements)